[Musica]
buonasera grazie di avermi invitato mi
dicono spesso che sembro una persona
dolce serena che riesco ad affrontare
una con
un sorriso anche le situazioni di
difficoltà che trasmette un senso di
pace
chi mi conosce bene sa che non è stato
sempre così che la mia cifra era
un'altra
io ero quella razionale io ero quella
severa
quando mi dicono questa cosa ripenso
agli ultimi 30 anni della mia vita
l'università il lavoro responsabilità
sempre crescenti
il tempo sempre scandito da impegni
continui cosa da fare obiettivi da
raggiungere problemi da risolvere
il tempo sempre pianificato al secondo
per non perderne neanche un istante per
non sprecarlo e così anche nel maggio
del 2008 quando per la prima volta sento
qualcosa che non va sul seno destro il
cancro al seno è di casa in famiglia ha
colpito mia nonna colpito mia sorella e
quindi io mi controllo regolarmente ogni
anno la mammografia è fissata dopo tre
mesi e io non penso di anticiparla non
ho tempo in agenda in quel momento
e poi a me non può capitare 24 luglio
giorno della mammografia
il medico è molto preoccupato il nodulo
già di 3 cm e devo fare una biopsia mi
dà il nome di un patologo suo amico e mi
dice di chiamarlo per fissarla
immediatamente io telefono al patologo e
non trovo spazio in agenda prima del
sabato successivo
non ho tempo da dedicare a questa cosa e
poi almeno un po capitare 29 luglio sono
in ufficio mi telefona il patologo per
dirmi che ai risultati dell'esame
però mi dice che vuole parlarmene di
persona mi dà appuntamento per il
pomeriggio alle 2
io arrivo in ospedale un po in anticipo
lui non c'è ancora e l'infermiera senza
pensarci mi dà una busta chiusa
arriva il dottore mi dice una parola
terribile carcinoma duttale triplo
negativo
poi mi spiega che un cancro molto
aggressivo e quindi dobbiamo eliminarlo
velocemente e mi dà il nome di un
chirurgo di milano che mi può operare
io non mi lascio prendere dal panico
faccio la cosa che so fare meglio mi
metto a pianificare chiamò subito la
segreteria del chirurgo fisso un un
appuntamento per fortuna lui è libero
menù da direttamente il pomeriggio
successivo sono a siena guardo
l'orologio faccio un po di calcoli e mi
metto in macchina per andare a milano
da quel momento il tempo scorre
velocissimo mi operano il 7 d'agosto il
10 di agosto sono di nuovo in ufficio e
comincia una trafila lunga lavoro
medicazioni lavoro radioterapia lavoro
chemioterapia dormo 12 ore a notte per
poter continuare a lavorare durante il
giorno
neanche i dosaggi della chemio che
devono essere modificati per due volte
ridotti perché non non assorbivo il
medicinale mi scuotono o un programma da
raggiungere voglio tornare
immediatamente alla mia vita normale
voglio riprendermi il mio tempo ma avevo
fatto i conti senza l'oste agosto del
2009 andiamo in vacanza ci mettiamo in
macchina per per andare in puglia e
durante il viaggio le prime avvisaglie
dopo qualche ora di guida
sono stanca e la mattina dopo sul
bagnasciuga sugli scogli
non riesco a stare in equilibrio
comincia a farsi in me la consapevolezza
che qualcosa è cambiato
non riesco a stare sveglia dopo l'ora di
cena anche un bicchiere di vino mi dà
alla testa
non riesco a portare pesi e come se
fossi invecchiata improvvisamente di 10
anni
anche in questo caso la razionalità
prevale torna a siena chiamo un medico
di medicina dello sport e lui mi dice
guarda se come un pugile suonato dopo
decine di match però non ti preoccupare
di rimettiamo in forma e così dopo un
anno di palestra piscina fisioterapia
finalmente l'agosto del 2010 riuscito
a goderci le vacanze evviva wonder woman
è tornata
o forse no in questi due anni sono
cambiate altre cose mio marito ha deciso
di andare in pensione per tornare a
vivere nella stessa città mio figlio ha
trovato un lavoro ed è andato a lavorare
all'estero
io sento l'urgenza di dare un senso
diverso a questo tempo che mi è stato
regalato parto dalle cose più semplici
comincio a trovare il tempo per le mie
amiche cosa che non facevo ormai da 30
anni
il sabato non devo più viaggiare quindi
comincio a fare volontariato cominciò a
riflettere su quella che può essere
l'evoluzione della mia vita ea 50 anni
nel 2013 trovo il coraggio per lasciare
un lavoro che drenava tutte le mie forze
e tutto il mio tempo per provare a
prendermi un po di tempo per me per
capire cosa fare da grande
comincio ad utilizzare un tempo diverso
il tempo dell'opportunità il tempo della
riflessione il tempo della buona
occasione di dollari con cedola
leggerezza di ascoltare le persone di
discutere delle mie opinioni e con chi
può avere anche un opinione diversa
dalla mia
di aprire il cuore la mente e lasciare
che i sogni mi portino soluzioni nuove a
problemi che sembravano insormontabili
in quell'anno conosco molte persone che
come me si sono ammalate di cancro e
parlando con loro mi rendo conto di una
cosa che probabilmente anch'io avevo
provato ma che non ero riuscita a
razionalizzare il cancro fa paura
e qual è la prima reazione che abbiamo
alla alla paura la negazione
anch'io avevo detto molte volte a me non
succederà invece dovete sapere che il
cancro colpisce in italia mille persone
al giorno
tanto per darvi un'idea diversa di di
questo numero è comunque un è un grande
dovete sapere che si stima che nell'arco
della propria vita un uomo su due è una
donna su tre in italia si ammaleranno di
cancro questa malattia è molto più
diffusa di quanto di quanto si pensi il
cancro fa paura il cancro è percepito
come una sentenza di morte
e vero ci sono dei cancri mo
e vero ci sono dei cancri molto
aggressivi ci sono dei cancri come il
cancro al polmone il cancro del fegato
al cancro all'ovaio che non lasciano
molte speranze di sopravvivere a lungo
tuttavia molti dei tumori più frequenti
hanno delle probabilità di sopravvivenza
molto più alte dovete sapere che di
dieci uomini che si ammaleranno di
cancro quest'anno più di cinque saranno
vivi ancora tra cinque anni di dieci
donne che si ammaleranno di cancro
quest'anno sei saranno ancora vive tra
cinque anni e molti di loro saranno
ancora vivi tra molti anni
tanto per darvi un altro numero ci sono
in italia oggi 3 milioni e 300mila
persone che sopravvivono al cancro e che
vuol dire che un italiano su 20 ha avuto
questa questa esperienza
c'è qualcosa che può fare la differenza
la differenza la fanno la diagnosi
precoce e la qualità della cura
io sono stata fortunata mi controllava
avevo un bravo senologo che ha trovato
il problema aveva un bravo patologo che
ha capito che era un calcio molto
aggressivo mi ha indirizzato a un centro
di cura che mi ha salvato la vita ma non
è sempre così
dovete sapere che ci sono in italia
tra i programmi di screening sui tre
tumori più frequenti e circa quattro
persone su dieci in italia il 40 per
cento non risponde alla chiamata di
screening anche se gratuita perché ha
paura della diagnosi e se guardate a
livello regionale ci sono regioni
soprattutto nel sud italia dove la
risposta agli screening è inferiore al
20 per cento
era una cosa che non potevo sopportare
dovevo fare qualcosa
allora ho cominciato a sì in effetti
questo anche un un altro risvolto che è
terribile
al sud ci si ammala di meno perché si
vive meglio gli stili di vita sono
migliori però si muore di più proprio
perché la gente fa meno prevenzione
allora ho cominciato a scrivere della
mia malattia ho cominciato a parlarne
tanti anni dopo che era successo perché
siamo nel 2013 e ho visto che
l'esperienza personale unita ad un
linguaggio semplice e comunque sempre
con un rigore scientifico delle
informazioni che davo nel nel mio blog
faceva presa
allora ho cominciato ad aggregare
intorno a me competenze diverse dalle
mie competenze che io non avevo che mi
potevano aiutare a trovare una soluzione
insieme a queste persone piano piano ci
siamo dati prima un un obiettivo provare
a capire se potevamo cambiare la
percezione del cancro una persona alla
volta e poi abbiamo trovato una
soluzione ci sono in italia 17 milioni
di persone
di lavoratori dipendenti se noi fossimo
riusciti ad arrivare a queste persone
alle loro famiglie avremmo fatto già un
enorme passo avanti
è così che è nato il
primo programma transmediale di
educazione alla prevenzione oncologica
in italia destinato alle aziende che si
vogliono prendere cura dei loro
dipendenti che hanno a cuore la salute
dei loro dipendenti
l'abbiamo chiamato nuovo in believe più
conoscenza meno paura
e questa sarà la mia prossima storia
grazie
[Musica]